Terminator: Dark Fate has arrived, and it's
safe to say that fans have a lot of questions.
Which works out really well, because we happen
to have a lot of answers!
Answers that require spoilers, of course.
With that warning, let's break down the ending
of Terminator: Dark Fate.
The first two thirds of Terminator: Dark Fate
set the table: a new evil Terminator model
called the Rev-9 has been sent from the future
to kill a Mexican woman named Daniella.
Luckily, someone also sent back a bionic woman
from the future named Grace to protect her.
Along with Sarah Connor, looking to get revenge
after her son John was killed by a Terminator,
they end up finding help from a very unlikely
source: Arnold Schwarzenegger's T-800, who
has been stuck in the past since killing John
after the events of Terminator 2.
The real surprise here, though, is that this
Terminator has voluntarily given up the terminating
business and has settled down in a human life
under the name Carl.
He embodies the core message from T2 that
people can choose their own fate and rewrite
their future.
He decided to stop being an evil killing machine,
and instead become a nurturing father figure.
It's an unexpected twist that suggests humans
and robots may actually be able to live together
in peace after all if the robots simply choose
a different path.
One of the big mysteries in Terminator: Dark
Fate is just why the robots have sent their
agent back in time to kill Dani.
During the final chase scene, though, Grace
reveals the truth: that Dani herself actually
becomes the resistance leader in the future.
As Sarah puts it, she's the new John Connor
the new last, best hope for all mankind.
Like Carl, Dani's character arc also reinforces
the idea that you can choose your own fate.
Several times in the film, the others urge
her to run and hide, but she instead insists
on fighting back.
She chooses to become the hero humanity needs,
and indeed, it's those choices that actually
make her a hero.
It's a real contrast to John, who often seemed
to reject the role of savior, only reluctantly
being pressed into it by circumstance.
John as a character seemed consigned by fate,
while Dani chooses her own path.
"I want to stand, and fight!"
The last third of Terminator: Dark Fate is
essentially one giant, neverending action
sequence that involves car chases, helicopters,
multiple plane crashes, gun fights, and a
Humvee getting swept over a dam, leading to
an underwater brawl.
It's such a whirlwind of non-stop excitement
that you may not have noticed it's all very,
very familiar.
Basically every action beat in Terminator:
Dark Fate is based off of something from a
previous Terminator installment.
In a way, that's thematically appropriate.
Even though Sarah successfully destroyed Skynet
in T2, which should have led to a happy future,
we learn instead that Skynet was just replaced
by a new AI called Legion.
The details of the future are different, but
the outline is still the same, just as the
details of Dark Fate are different from the
previous films, but the plot is still the
same.
The message now seems to be the opposite of
T2: in Dark Fate, no matter what you do, nothing
ever really changes your destiny.
In the climax of the film, the whole team
of good guys faces off against the Rev-9,
which seems unfair until you consider the
Rev-9 has the ability to split into two different,
self-sufficient robots - a metal exoskeleton
like the T-800, and a fluid form like the
T-1000.
The only way the good guys are able to win
is by Grace sacrificing herself so Dani can
take Grace's power source and jam it into
Rev-9's eyehole, causing it to melt down.
As it happens, fans have seen this before,
because that's almost exactly how Arnold's
good guy Terminator defeated the evil T-X
in Terminator 3: he removes his power core
and shoves it in the T-X's mouth, whereupon
it explodes and destroys both of them.
We're not sure if this is a loving homage
to Terminator 3, or if they just assumed everyone
had forgotten Terminator 3 existed at all.
Either could be true!
With the power core delivered to the Rev-9's
head, there's just one last thing that needs
to happen: a sad descent into the pit where
both the villainous Rev-9 and the heroic T-800
model known as Carl blink their final blinky
lights.
It's sad or at least it's supposed to be sad,
because it's very intentionally calling back
memories of the infamous ending of T-2.
You remember that one, right?
It's the one with the thumbs up!
It's obvious director Tim Miller is hoping
the memory of T2's tearjerker ending will
add some much needed gravitas to the climax
of Terminator: Dark Fate.
Avengers: Endgame isn't the only action movie
this year that gets its emotional resonance
from the films that came before.
"I love you 3000!"
That's not the final "moving" moment designed
to play on peoples' emotions, though.
The final scene of Terminator: Dark Fate is
designed to deliver a double subliminal whammy
to anyone who has seen Terminator and T2.
Dani and Sarah Connor are at a playground,
where they watch a young and oblivious Grace
playing with her family.
After Dani vows to make sure Grace doesn't
have to sacrifice herself, she and Sarah jump
in a waiting vehicle and drive off to prepare
for the impending Armageddon.
The playground element, of course, is a clear
reference to the infamous playground scene
in T2 where Sarah connnor watches families
get incinerated by the Skynet-caused nuclear
holocaust.
And the "riding into the sunset" ending is
exactly the same as the end of the first Terminator
film only this time, instead of being pregnant
with the future savior of humanity that she
has to train, Sarah Connor is riding shotgun
with her.
Structurally, Terminator: Dark Fate is almost
identical to the original Terminator film,
in much the same way that Star Wars: Episode
VII The Force Awakens is a soft reboot of
the original Star Wars: Episode IV A New Hope.
So we actually have a pretty good idea where
they could go with the next film in the series
a new version of T2!
Sure, the plot would actually have to be pretty
different, but the main thrust of T2 was the
attempt to prevent Armageddon by destroying
Skynet.
In Dark Fate, they don't ever have the chance
to even think about stopping the apocalypse,
but they could certainly try to take steps
in Terminator 7 to prevent the new AI, Legion,
from coming to be.
One thing is for sure: we can't wait to find
out which beloved scenes from the previous
Terminator films they'll remake in the next
one!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.